nous étions engagés sur plusieurs
initiatives certes pas très importante
sur les questions de prévention de la
radicalisation j'avais demandé à
Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui de nous aider à
aller dans cette direction et nous faire
bénéficier de son expertise entre fin
2020 et début 2021 au lendemain d'un
horrible attentat que tout le monde
garde en mémoire Mohamed Tifaoui m'a
fait savoir que les pouvoirs publics et
plus précisément le cabinet de Madame
Schiappa lui avait demandé de prendre
part à des actions de contre discours
pour répondre à la propagande islamiste
la première quinzaine de janvier j'ai
pris un café avec monsieur cifaoui qui
m'a demandé si je trouvais intéressantes
l'idée de mettre en application un
projet qu'il avait déjà au sein de
l'icep
il m'a alors dit sans me donner toutes
les précisions qu'il discutait avec
plusieurs responsables du ministère de
l'Intérieur qu'il l'encouragé à
s'engager dans cette perspective
je vous précise que le projet en
question était très ambitieux c'est allé
sur plusieurs années et nécessité la
mise en place de moyens considérables
notamment parce qu'il fallait investir
dans des moyens humains
par la suite je j'aurais pu vous donner
les dates exactes mais il m'en a reparlé
en février mars c'est ainsi que le 7
avril 2021 monsieur Mohammed VI ah oui
me transfère un email d'un conseiller de
Madame Schiappa qui lui adresse les
pièces du dossier à renseigner pour
bénéficier d'une subvention
et Monsieur Sifaoui m'appelle dans la
foulée pour me dire que nous n'avons que
deux jours pour envoyer un dossier
complet au ci PDR
j'ai donc dû arrêter séance tenante tout
ce que je faisais et j'ai travaillé jour
et nuit pour pouvoir être dans les temps
avec du recul monsieur le président
je me dis que ce jour-là
j'aurais dû refuser d'envoyer cette
demande de subvention
bon c'est toujours facile de commenter
les événements quand ils sont passés
mais voilà non seulement parce que j'ai
commis des erreurs en travaillant dans
la précipitation mais en plus d'une
certaine façon ce mauvais départ allait
perturber le projet auquel nous avons
pensé initialement